landz und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus wo erreich ich dich
in der
kenate du denkst wieer das finde ich gut
rich wir haben letztes Mal eine eine
Folge gemacht über über den großen
Rückschritt ja und und wir haben das so
ein bisschen in der Deutsch betrachtet
um es mal so zu sagen und gab wahnsinnig
viel Resonanz darauf und du hast schon
letztes Mal gesagt wir sollten auch mal
den Blick nach außen Wagen und da kam
jetzt Barack Obama ins Spiel ich habe
eine eine Rede von ihm gesehen vor
seiner Stiftung und musste sehr an ein
Gespräch denken dass ich dieser Tage mit
dem 91 Jahre alten Gerhard Baum geführt
habe habe der sagte ich bin Kriegskind
ich habe den Krieg noch in den Knochen
aber das was wir gerade erleben das habe
auch ich so noch nicht erlebt und wir
reden jetzt von einem Mann der ist fast
100 Jahre alt der überblickt fast 100
Jahre Barack Obama den ich vor ein paar
Jahren mal getroffen habe und der mich
damals so beeindruckt hat weil er für
mich tatsächlich so ein bisschen ja wie
soll man sagen das ist ein ein Mensch
der kommt rein und den hättest du gerne
als Vater der du hast immer das Gefühl
der umarmt dich geistig das ist einer
wenn der da ist dann weißt du es wird
alles gut und genauso in diesem Geist
hat er jetzt wieder diese Rede gehalten
ich will es gar nicht seine auf auf
seine Politik weiter eingehen und so
weiter ich will nur sagen dieses Gefühl
dass man mit diesem Menschen verbindet
und Gefühle sind gerade in diesen Tagen
so wichtig das Gefühl aufgehoben zu sein
sich sicher zu fühlen das ist ja das was
uns gerade so fehlt und deswegen
vermisst man denn dann auch so die Art
und Weise wie er redet die Art und Weise
wie er vort trägt was er sagt das
kontrastiert alles so unglaublich hart
mit so jemandem wie Donald Trump
beispielsweise und dieser Barack Obama
sagt im Grunde das was Gerhard Baum auch
sagt der sagt die Welt fühlt sich gerade
so instabil und gefährlich an wie schon
lange nicht mehr der dritte im Bunde
harari den wir beide schätzen sagt vor
10 Jahren gab es so wenige Kriege auf
der Welt wie noch nie in der Geschichte
der Menschheit aber jetzt hört das auf
die friedlichste era in der Geschichte
der Menschheit geht zu Ende und nicht
nur das nicht nur Kriege beginnen wieder
starten die andere versuchen wirklich
auszulöschen also Tiefe Konflikte
sondern es sind zurück die Pandemien und
viele viele andere Dinge und über das
Klima haben wir in dem Zusammenhang noch
gar nicht gesprochen und die Rede von
Obama atmet auch genau diesen Geist die
sagt nämlich es ist wahnsinnig schwer
wenn man sich das alles mal so ganz
nüchtern anschaut an so einem grauen
Novembertag hier in Hamburg es ist irre
schwer ein bisschen Zuversicht und ein
bisschen Hoffnung zu schöpfen gerade und
das ist das Gefühl finde ich dass wir
alle gerade Teilen ja ich glaube
ausnahmslos also ich kenne auch in
meinem Umfeld und ich komme ja nun auch
viel rum mit Vorträgen und Gesprächen
und so weiter eigentlich kaum jemand der
gegenwärtig optimistisch noch in die
Zukunft blickt also wenn man sich an den
den Schwung der Obama Zeit erinnert ne
yes we can wenn ich daran denke dass wir
vor einiger Zeit noch das Gefühl hatten
jetzt ist die Zeit großer neuer
gesellschaftlicher Verbesserungen
Utopien angebrochen wir Steven Pinker
über den wir mal gesprochen haben ne
dieser evolutionäre Psychologe der
gesagt hat es gibt allen Grund zu
Optimismus weil es gibt heute viel
weniger Kriege in der Welt viel weniger
Menschen sterben relativ zur
Weltbevölkerung an Hunger verglichen mit
früheren Zeiten und so weiter sagt eent
eigentlich wird alles besser im Spiegel
gab's sogar so eine Rubrik die immer
aufzeigte was heute alles viel besser
ist als es früher war und das früher
eigentlich fast gar nichts besser war
und dieses Gefühl ist jetzt wirklich
komplett weg also man kann sagen
innerhalb von 5 Jahren vielleicht erst
die erst die Erschütterung durch die
Pandemie im Grunde beginnt das ganze
jaah mit der mit der großen Migration
und dann kommt die Pandemie dazu dann
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
jetzt der der ostkonflikt von dem man
gewaltige Angst hat dass er sich immer
weiter ausbreitet zu einem Flächenbrand
also da hat hat das Gefühl die
Geschichte läuft auf einmal rückwärts
und nicht mehr vorwärts ne also dieser
dieser grundoptimismus der sehr sehr
wichtig ist für die westlichen
Gesellschaften wir können die Dinge
immer weiter zur Humanität bringen ja
wir müssen demokratischer werden wir
müssen liberaler werden wir müssen mehr
Handel betreiben wir müssen mehr
Wohlstand generieren aber auf diese Art
und Weise wird on the long run die Welt
irgendwann ein immer immer immer
besserer Ort und aus dieser Erzählung
sind wir so richtig rausgekint genau ich
hab dieser Tage Florence Gau gesprochen
die ein tolles Buch übrigens empfehle
ich sehr über die Zukunft geschrieben
hat und die gar nicht so pessimistisch
in die Welt schaut vielleicht reden wir
auch gleich noch ein bisschen darüber
und und zwar gegen Ende hin aber die
natürlich auch so diese Analyse macht
und sagt da gibt es jetzt die Ukraine
Israel Gaza Bergkarabach ja was alles so
passiert die ganze Weltordnung scheint
so aus den vogen zu geraten und sie sagt
ja täusch dich aber nicht all diese
Kriege sind Nachfahren sozusagen Kinder
von Konflikten ist interessanter Gedanke
die nie richtig aufgelöst worden sind ja
und sie sagt viele Menschen wollen dass
der Krieg in der Ukraine endlich vorbei
ist aber wichtiger ist dass er so
beendet wird dass er nicht wieder
ausbricht sie sagt das was wir da gerade
auch erleben das ist nicht ein ganz
spannenden Gedanken ist im Grunde das
Ergebnis von 30 Jahren schlampiger
Konfliktlösung und so hat Obama in
dieser Rede auch ausgedrückt oder so
ähnlich der sagte das was wir da im
Nahen Osten sehen das ist sozusagen ein
Konflikt der sich seit so so langer Zeit
hinzieht und wir haben es vergeigt so so
ungefähr sagt das wir haben es
vermasselt wir haben es nicht
hingekriegt das irgendwann mal zu
befriedenen ja ich glaube das stimmt
völlig wenn man ein bisschen Optimismus
schöpfen will auf eine merkwürdige Art
auch sagen eigentlich geht's jetzt so
weiter wie es immer in der Menschheit
war und die Ausnahmezeit die war nur
davor ne also das ist so heftige
Auseinandersetzungen äh gegeben hat und
dass es überall Kriege gab und
Auseinandersetzung das begleitet ja die
Geschichte der Menschheit von ihren
Anfängen an und die große Ausnahmezeit
waren halt die die Jahrzehnte in denen
wir beide aufgewachsen sind die waren
auch nicht frei von Konflikten und von
Spannungen bei weitem nicht und trotzdem
hatte man aber in dieser Zeit das Gefühl
es wird alles doch irgendwie ja siee
pinker irgendwie doch besser und nicht
schlechter und dass das jetzt verloren
gegangen ist dann wenn man versucht eine
Analyse zu finden dann kann man ja sagen
ja ist ja ja vielleicht auch logisch
dass das so ist das hängt ja alles damit
zusammen dass sich die geopolitische
Plattentektonik massiv verschiebt und
zwar aufgrund des enormen
wirtschaftlichen Erfolges der
asiatischen Länder einen vor an China
aber auch Indien und auch dem dem neuen
Selbstbewusstsein des seit einiger Zeit
sogenannten globalen Südens und parallel
dazu wird die Bedeutung Amerikas weiter
absinken und möglicherweise eben auch
die Bedeutung Europas und zwar sowohl
wirtschaftlich wie damit eben auch
weltpolitisch und solche Zeiten in denen
eine
Hegemonialmacht an Macht und Einfluss
verliert und die Geschicke nicht mehr
überall in der Welt bestimmen kann in so
einem Moment brechen erstmal ganz
unruhige Zeiten an also das letzte Mal
standen wir vor so einer Situation als
das britische Empire das britische
Empire war ja vergleichbar mächtig damit
wie mächtig die heute die USA bis in
unsere Zeit gewesen sind also die USA
sind sozusagen der große Hegemon seit
1945 und im 19 Jahrhundert waren es die
Briten das viktorianische Zeitalter das
britische Empire und als das begann zu
bröckeln so um die Jahrhundertwende
führte das dann in die Zeit des Ersten
Weltkrieges Deutschland war das China
der damaligen Zeit ja das war der
newcammer Deutschland hatte eine sehr
verspätete Gründung als Nation
Deutschland war ewig ein Flickenteppich
aus Kleinstaaten gewesen der deswegen
politisch keine große Rolle spielen
konnte dann kam 1871 mit Bismark die
Reichseinigung und ein irrsinniger
wirtschaftlicher Aufschwung wir waren
das ist ein schöner Vergleich wir waren
das China der damaligen Zeit genau wir
waren der sozusagen der neue Rivale der
forderte die alten Mächte heraus und ich
meine es gibt viele Gründe und Umstände
wir haben ja auch davon gesprochen über
Kar und die Schlafwandler was dann
schlussendlich zu einem Krieg geführt
hat den in dieser Form niemand gewollt
hat niemand wollte einen Weltkrieg und
schon gar nicht ein der vier Jahre
dauert bei Ausbruch des Ersten
Weltkrieges dachten die beteiligten
Nationen also V all die hauptsächlich
beteiligt wie die Engländer die
Deutschen die
Franzosen die Russen das die
Österreicher das ist vielleicht eine
Sache von paar Wochen niemand hat sich
einen Weltkrieg vorstellen können
niemand hat sich vorstellen können dass
das moderne Kriegsgerät was man hatte
und das zum großen Teil noch gar nicht
eingesetzt worden war was für verherende
Auswirkung das für ein Krieg hatte ja
dieser absurde Stellungskrieg in
Frankreich in Verdon ja in diesen
Schützengräben wo also immer wieder
Menschen nach vorne getrieben wurde in
einen Krieg der gar nicht zu gewinnen
war weil die von der Artillerie sofort
zerfetzt wurden da war quasi das das
Denken der Militärs noch im 19
Jahrhundert aber die kriegstechnologie
bereits im 20 und die gesamte Mentalität
die Geisteshaltung der Menschen dass man
mit kriegen Realpolitik betreiben könne
ne Bismark hat strategisch Kriege
geführt gegen Frankreich z.B ja oder
gegen Dänemark um die die Interessen des
Deutschen Reiches durchzusetzen das ging
die Kriege dauert nicht besonders lange
und Deutschland hat sie gewonnen und so
dachte man auch 1914 noch ja Realpolitik
ne wir holen uns jetzt was durch den
Krieg ne wir hauen den anderen mal
richtig ein auf die Mütze und das war
alles nicht mehr zeitgemäß die poante
ist die Geisteshaltung ist viel
langsamer vorangeschritten oder gar
nicht während sich drumherum die Welt
völlig verändert hat es geht um das
neuabstecken des Terrains also ich hatte
damals
am Anfang des ukrainekrieges zu dir im
Podcast gesagt das ist das Ende der PAX
Amerikaner ja genau ich erinnere mich ja
das heißt also mehr und mehr Staaten ja
sagen sich egal was die USA will ja oder
egal ob es gegen die Interessen der USA
ist das heißt also das Selbstbewusstsein
der Länder ist massiv erstarkt und das
gilt für Russland das gilt für China das
gilt auch für indienen Rolle wiren das
für Brasilien überhaupt für den gesamten
sogenannten globalen Süden der sich ja
jetzt die brickstaaten sind ja dabei
sich noch stark zu erweitern viele
andere Länder mit aufzunehmen sechs
glaube ich ne sechs Staaten dazu
gekommen und die repräsentieren das ist
auch mal interessant zu hören der bricks
ne steht ja für Brasilien Russland
Indien China Südafrika und sechs weitere
die repräsentieren die Hälfte der
Weltbevölkerung und ich fand es
interessant als das jetzt so kam war
sofort die erste Kommentierung vor den
müssen wir keine Angst haben und ich
dachte interessant was wir uns mal
wieder für eine Arroganz leisten und
sagen die sind wirschaftlich so schwach
und die sind sich auch nicht einig
dachte wann wann verstehen wir mal dass
es jetzt mal Zeit ist für zumindest eine
kleine Runde demot in dem ganzen
Zusammenhang es ist vor einigen Zeit
darüber nachzudenken wie wird denn die
Welt sein und wir wer wird wie die Welt
gestalten wenn der Westen also die USA
und die Europäer ihre Vormachtstellung
verlieren und eben nicht mehr darüber
bestimmen wie gehen wir damit um und da
gibt es ja grundsätzlich zwei
Möglichkeiten eine Möglichkeit ist wir
versuchen die anderen mit aller Gewalt
klein zu halten das würde aber
mutmaßlich irgendwann vielleicht
tatsächlich in noch gewaltigere Kriege
ausarten und das andere ist wir müssen
uns mit den aufstrebenden Mächten auf
neue Art und Weise arrangieren das hat
das großen Nachteil der wertekonflikte
über die wir ja sicher gleich reden
werden und äh mit was man sich
arrangiert und mit was man sich nicht
arrangiert aber ich glaube der erste Weg
ist auf die Dauer nicht gangbar das
Merkwürdige ist doch natürlich hat der
Westen eine irrsinnige militärische
Überlegenheit gegenüber dem Rest aber
wir erleben äh anhand des Krieges jetzt
in der Ukraine dass wir z.B ich habe ja
immer gedacht weißt du ein Krieg wenn
man Atomwaffen hat dann gibt's ja
eigentlich in dem großen Sinne zwischen
Atomstaaten keine konventionellen kriege
aber wenn beide Seiten aus guten Gründen
keine Atomwaffen einsetzen dann werden
es ja doch wieder herkömmliche
konventionelle Kriege die haben sich
aber inzwischen auch unglaublich
verändert Drohnen scheinen auf einmal
wichtiger als Panzer also alles so wie
man sich bisher Krieg vorgestellt hat
alles ist irgendwie ganz ganz anders ja
und am Ende zählt es dann doch noch wie
viel Soldaten das jeweilige Land hat wo
man sagen würde in so hochtechnisierten
Zeiten kann muss das doch die
unwichtigste Frage sein ist es überhaupt
nicht ja spielt immer noch eine
gigantische Rolle und alles das was wir
jetzt aus aus diesen fürchterlichen zwei
Jahren des Krieges in der Ukraine lernt
zeigt ja eigentlich dass auf
militärische Art und Weise diese
Konflikte nicht mehr gelöst werden
können und zwar weder für die eine Seite
noch für die andere Seite und die Frage
ist wenn das nicht mehr geht ja was sind
denn dann die Möglichkeiten wie man
solche Auseinandersetzungen
und und wie man Kriege vermeidet wie man
Eskalationen vermeidet und das alles vor
dem Horizont ja eines immer noch
möglichen dritten Weltkrieges aufgrund
eines Flächenbrandes aufgrund von
Kettenreaktion ähnlich wie beim Ersten
Weltkrieg m genau wo man so langsam
reingestolpert ist ne das ist auch
manchmal so eine wenn man mit mit
Militärstrategen spricht ich ich kenne
mich da glücklicherweise nicht aus ich
habe neulich mit mit Carlo Masala
darüber geredet und habe gemerkt
in welcher Welt ich eigentlich groß
geworden bin wie weit weg das alles ist
und mal so ein bisschen Hoffnung an
einen hoffnungsvollen Gedanken ja in
unser Gespräch jetzt hier zu bringen ja
den Leuten macht die aktuelle weltklage
Angst und als eines der Argumente kommt
dann häufig weißt du früher Kalter Krieg
das waren stabile Pole ja da war auf der
einen Seite da waren die Amerikaner auf
der anderen Seite die Sowjetunion oder
die Russen und das war irgendwie
berechenbar aber das ist glaube ich eine
rückschauanalyse ja wenn du heute da
drauf schaust dann sagst du dieser Kalte
Krieg hatte
irgendwie auf paradoxe Weise einen
stabilisierenden Effekt ja sowohl als
aber wenn du dich nicht ich will nur der
Gedanke wenn du wenn du dein
Lebensgefühl aber mal versuchst noch mal
aus deinem Hinterkopf zu holen dass wir
damals hatten als wir aufgewachsen sind
also das Gefühl dass das stabilisierend
ist hatte ich nie sondern man hatte
immer das Gefühl da gibt es eine große
Bedrohung da war hab plötzlich diese
Atomwaffen und man hatte das Gefühl wir
tänzeln die ganze Zeit an so einem
Abgrund das war das Lebensgefühl von
damals und deswegen muss man auch
jüngere die dann das manchmal so
analysieren und sagen du pass auf das
war doch damals für euch eine bessere
Zeit nein nein nein nein weiß nicht und
ich ich will das sozusagen nicht nicht
rechtfertigen in irgendeiner Form so
nach der Motto unsere Kindheit war
genauso furchtbar wie eure aber wir will
nur sagen die rückschauanalyse ist
häufig da sehr viel optimistischer und
besser als es tatsächlich war
was wiederum auch auch ne was und auch
da sind wir rausgekommen für eine lange
Zeit und dachten ja eine Zeitlang sogar
da kommt jetzt unser
Francis Fukuyama ins Spiel das Ende der
Geschichte als dieses riesige
sowjetimerium mit allem was da drum und
dran hät kollabierte sprach eher ja von
dieser berühmte Satz vom Ende der
Geschichte man hatte das Gefühl jetzt
setzen sich die guten und das sind
selbstverständlich wir für immer und
ewig durch es ist vorbei wir haben es
geschafft wir haben es geschafft genau
ja und vor allen und die große
militärische Bedrohung ist weg also muss
man immer sagen die größte Angst ne als
kleiner Nachtrag hatte ich immer vor
systemischen Unfällen also die Angst
davor dass irgendwo ein Fehlalarm
ausgelöst wird dass irgendwas
missinterpretiert wird und dass ein
Atomkrieg entsteht ich meine beide
Seiten waren ja klar sie gewinnen keinen
Atomkrieg und sie vernichten die ganze
Welt aber dass es trotzdem ausgelöst
werden kann durch Missverständnisse und
wie wir wissen war es ja auch einmal wei
ich 82 oder 83 ganz ganz ganz knapp und
es gab ja Film die diese Auswirkung
auszeigten ja von the day after der
eigentlich im Grunde genommen sogar
verhamlosend war ja bis Wargames und so
weiter wo sich ein Hacker irgendwie in
die Systeme einhckt und dadurch den
Dritten Weltkrieg auslöst oder fast
auslöst also diese Ängste die waren
wirklich massiv in der damaligen Zeit
und dann ne die große Erleichterung dass
durch die Implosion der Sowjetunion die
ja die ja auf jämmerliche Art und Weise
Zug Grunde ging ne also sozusagen dieser
große gefährliche Gegner der sich ja in
Rauch auflöst
ja und und dann von bis Jelzin regiert
wurde den man auch locker mit Whisky und
Wodka über den Tisch ziehen konnte woll
sagen ich glaube es war tendenziell mehr
Wodka als Whisky ich weiß nicht irgendwo
auch Whisky angeboten hat na ja also
jedenfalls aber er hat immer sehr gute
Laune lass es uns so sagen ja hatte ein
rotes Gesicht und ein heiteres Gemüt ja
aber man hatte e hatte aber das Gefühl
dass damit die militärische Bedrohung ja
weg ist und das war natürlich eine
gigantische Erleichterung gegenüber den
den Situationen vorher und dann kommt
Francis fukoyama junger Politologe
damals aus der japanischen
Einwandererfamilie und erinnert sich an
den Satz von Hegel vom Ende der
Geschichte also berühmte Formel von
Hegel ja der meinte dass so um das Jahr
1830 rum oder Ende 1820er Jahren im
Grunde genommen in dem preußischen
Obrigkeitsstaat Friedrich Willems des
dritten in Preußen alles so optimal
geregelt sei dass man sich besser
eigentlich nicht vorstellen konnte also
jedenfalls unter realistischen
menschheitsbedingungen ne es gibt keine
Harmonie auf Erden aber so ist das doch
alles gar nicht so schlecht und der arme
Hegel hatte erleben müssen dass die
Engländer dann ihr Wahlrecht veränderten
übrigens zum Positiven ne es sollten
also nicht nur die die eine kleine
Schicht von Adeligen wählen dürfen
sondern die reichen Bürger sollten auch
noch mitwählen dürfen und noch ein paar
Bürger mehr war er gegen warum weil er
nicht wollte dass ich in der Geschichte
jetzt so viel verändert und neue
Dynamiken passieren und dann 1830 gab es
in Frankreich eine Revolution war
natürlich auch gegen
ja weil das Geschichte sollte ja
eigentlich zu Ende
sein schön ist schön od auf gegen diese
Revolution bin ich total weil es
zerstört meine schöne These richtig
genau
das also jetzt hör doch mal bitte mit
dem Quatsch auf hab das nicht verstanden
aber aber fukoyamas Irrtum vom Ende der
Geschichte ist tragischer ist wirklich
weitgehend tragischer weil das war ja
eine sehr schöne Hoffnung die ich auch
geteilt habe nämlich die die Hoffnung zu
sagen wir haben doch am Beispiel des
Zusammenbruchs des staatskommunismus
gesehen so läuft das nicht ja sondern
die absolut überlegen Form das wusste
man ja eigentlich auch vorher schon ja
sind die liberalen Demokratien die
kapitalistisch wirtschaftenden liberalen
Demokratien soziale Marktwirtschaft und
Fukuyama ein absoluter europafan und
Deutschland Fan nicht so ein richtiger
USA Fan also er meinte nicht die
Geschichte ist zu Ende weil die USA
gewonnen haben sondern er hat gesagt das
was die Deutschen machen was die
Europäer machen
ig das ist so optimal und das werden die
anderen sich über kurz oder lang abgcken
und am Anfang hatte er recht ja in der
Anfang der 90er Mitte der 90 90er Jahre
sind die Zeit in der sich viele Länder
irgendwie muss man sagen in Demokratien
verwandeln und deswegen sah das lange
ziemlich gut für ihn aus manche wurden
auch nur umetikettiert ne wie man heute
weiß ja die häufigste die häufigste
Regierungsform für die gibt es
verschiedene
Namen richtig gute Demokratien sind
selten lupenreine Autokratien sind auch
recht selten ja also die königtümer
vielleicht also Saudi-Arabien oder Katar
das sind lupenreine Autokratien aber die
häufigste Form das sind
anokratien Hybride Regime und geführte
Demokratien sind eigentlich drei Worte
für das gleiche das ist sius wie eine
Demokratie ist aber keine das sind die
mit Abstand häufigsten Regierungsformen
das GT für
ö formal ist das in Demokratie da gibt
es Wahlen ja manchmal vielleicht sogar
nicht manipulierte we nicht notwendig
ist du hast zwar einen Präsidenten
gewählt und Parlament und was weiß ich
was aber es ist ein informelles
Herrschaftssystem die Geheimdienste
regieren Oligarchen regieren bestimmen
machen die Rechtssprechung wird
manipuliert und und und das heißt die
Kräfte die die wirkliche Politik
bestimmen die sind nicht gewählt und das
sind eigentlich die häufigsten Formen
die wir heute haben und das scheint ein
unheimlich erfolgreiches Modell zu sein
weil das greift immer weiter um sich und
wir sehen auch wie sich Demokratien an
vielen Orten anfangen in anokratien zu
verwandeln man denke an Ungarn und
vieles andere mehr ich habe gerade
Richard weil du weil wir kurz über den
über den Kalten Krieg gesprochen haben
und du sagtest da standen wir mehrfach
am Abgrund Kubakrise war ein solcher
Moment z.B das war wirklich knapp und
ich bin neulich gestolpert über einen
Mann dessen Name ich nicht mehr drauf
hat
Stanislav Petrov sagt ihr der Name was
ist das der Name von dem Russen der da
verhindert hat da der der so so ein
Oberst oder so der da nicht auf den
Knopf gedrückt hat genau 26 September 83
der sitzt in einem Bunker na im Moskau
ja und überwacht den usluftraum und
plötzlich gibt's Alarm Abschuss erst
einer und dann vier weitere
US-amerikanische
Atomraketen so und jetzt die Frage ja
Atomangriff jetzt muss natürlich der
Gegenschlag kommen und das könnte die
Auslöschung der gesamten Menschheit
bedeuten aber
petrof deswegen muss man diesen Mann mal
erinnern misstraut diesem
Frühwarnsystem und sagt ja im im
Ernstfall würden die USA nicht nur von
einer Raketenbasis aus angreifen das ist
komisch was hier passiert ja und meldet
einen Fehlalarm und hat recht weil
sonnenreflektionen wie sich hinterher
rausstellen für ein ein Fehler bei
diesem Warensystem
gesorgt haben und die Sowjetführung
macht das was sie immer macht sie
verschweigt diesen Vorfall erst nach dem
Zerfall der Sowjetunion erfährt man von
von diesem Stanislav Petrov und ein Mann
der deswegen kennen wir den auch ein
bisschen so im Hinterkopf hat man den
der wird im Westen dafür gefeiert in
Russland kennt den vermutlich kein
Mensch das nur mal zu sagen es gibt dann
so stille Helden des Alltags wenn man so
will die an ganz entscheidenden Momenten
der menschheits Geschichte dafür sorgen
dass es in die gute Richtung läuft und
nicht in die schlimme Richtung läuft so
einfach ist das manchmal ja man kann
sich auch nur hoffen es gäbe auch im
Zeitalter künstlicher Intelligenz die am
Ende dann darüber entscheidet was ein
Angriff ist und wenn nicht ein
petrofaktor der da irgendwo
eingearbeitet wird ne das wäre
unglaublich wichtig aber die die Frage
die am meisten natürlich mich bewegt ist
warum hatte Fukuyama Unrecht also wenn
es den doch so ist dass liberale
Demokratien sehr erfolgreich sind wenn
es ist das kapitalistisches Wirtschaften
unendlich erfolgreicher ist als dieser
staatskommunismus äh im Ostblock gewesen
ist oder in China gewesen ist dann hätte
sie sich das ja doch allmählich
durchsetzen müssen und da das weckt
natürlich den Sinn für das nachdenken
warum das erst so gut aussah und warum
sich das dann verändert hat und das eine
scheint mir darin zu liegen dass unsere
liberalen Demokratien nur dann so
wahnsinnig erfolgreich sind wenn das mit
der wohlstandsmährung auch gut klappt
und das liegt nicht nur daran dass ein
Land liberal und demokratisch ist
sondern das hängt natürlich auch davon
ab welche Bodenschätze es hat welche
Handelspartner es hat und so weiter ne
also viele Faktoren die eine Rolle
spielen und wenn sich die äußere
Gemengelage verändert dann kann das sein
dass wohlstandsentwicklungen nicht mehr
weitergehen und dass wir in Deutschland
unheimlich sensibel darauf reagieren
wenn der Wohlstand nicht mehr wächst da
müssen wir nicht lange drüber nachdenken
und was passiert dann in liberalen
Demokratien ja es entstehen Parteien die
anfangen mit den liberalen Demokratien
wie sie sind zu fremdeln das entsteht
ein
der sich gegen die bestehende Politik
richtet das heißt also die Länder werden
instabiler so das ist in Deutschland
jetzt nicht besonders dramatisch aber es
gibt ja viele andere Länder bei denen
das eben sehr viel dramatischer ist oder
wo dann diese Populisten selber an der
Macht sind ne wie das in Polen war oder
wie das in Ungarn war und das andere das
scheint mir noch viel wichtiger zu sein
ist früher war die Sowjetunion für uns
ein systemischer Rivale ja entweder
Kommunismus oder Kapitalismus ich würde
die These Wagen ein systemischer Rivale
waren die Russen nur bis Anfang der 70er
Jahre wenn danach hat kein Sowjetführer
mehr daran geglaubt dass der Kommunismus
überlegen ist also Stalin mag das
vielleicht geglaubt haben Lenin hat es
mit Sicherheit geglaubt und krustschof
hat wohl noch geglaubt ne mit den
Erfolgen die sie de der Raumfahrt hatten
aber seit breschnieev ging es do nur
noch um eins zu sichern was man hat woll
sagen es genügt ja einen Blick in die
Supermarktregale ja um zu wissen dass
das nicht das überlegende System sein
kann jeder Sowjetführer WUs dass sein
System nicht überlegen ist sondern es
ging darum das bestehende System zu
halten zu retten und so weiter mit immer
mehr mit Militär und entsprechender
Machtpolitik und der breschnf Doktrin
dass sich die Länder im Osten Europas
nicht verändern durften damit die
weiterhin im Machtbereich blieben weil
man ins geheim natürlich wusste dass man
der systemische Verlierer
ist China war für uns überhaupt keine
Bedrohung solange sie Kommunisten waren
weil sie waren wirtschaftlich unter mau
mega
unerfolgreich erst als sie unter dengen
einen anderen Kurs eingeschlagen hatten
wurde China ja überhaupt ein Global
Player ja dann wurde China immer immer
erfolgreicher wir fanden das wahnsinnig
toll dass es so erfolgreich wurde weil
gigantischeer Absatzmarkt und Rohstoffe
und so Deutschland hat ungemein davon
profitiert aber seit die Kapitalisten in
China so dermaßen erfolgreich sind
fordern Sie natürlich auch politisch
global immer mehr Mitbestimmung und das
ist jetzt was was uns überhaupt nicht
mehr gefällt das heißt also China ist
vor allenigen deswegen für uns so eine
Herausforderung weil sie keine
systemischen Rivalen mehr sind ja weil
sie keine keine Maoisten der
Kulturrevolution mehr sind sondern weil
sie viel abgefeimtere Kapitalisten sind
als wir selbst weil sie uns in Afrika
den Rang abgelaufen haben in Südamerika
den Rang abgelaufen haben sich Rohstoffe
in aller Welt gesichert haben wie das
Gute Kapitalisten so machen das heißt
also das kapitalistische China mit
seiner kommunistischen Verbrämung ja ist
eigentlich die viel größere
Herausforderung als es das richtig
kommunistische China von früher gewesen
ist genau du ne wir haben mal über
diesen den gen Koeffizienten gesprochen
ne Corado Geni italienischer Statistiker
auf den das zurückgeht wo sozusagen die
Ungleichheit in Ländern misst und der
Unterschied zwischen wirklich wahnsinnig
Armen ich meine sind immer noch ich
glaub 20% der chinesischen Bevölkerung
sind nach wie vor Arm also bei allen
Erfolgen die du dann immer so hörst und
wenn du dieses gigantische
Wirtschaftswachstum liest und so weiter
und der Unterschied zwischen zwischen
denen und den den Milliardären die fast
im Wochenrhythmus in in China quasi
geboren werden der ist einfach
gigantisch es gibt kein Land ind dem das
die Ungleichheit so groß ist wie China
äh in Amerika ist es auch frappierend
aber in China ist es besonders
brutaltig
genau anders meine 600 Millionen
Menschen sind in China von unter derze
nach oben gehoben worden das ist
natürlich etwas was sehr große
innenpolitische Stabilität schafft ne
weil sie sagen die Wohlstandsentwicklung
der der letzten Jahrzehnte die ist ja
enorm gewesen in China obwohl es diese
Armut gibt ne ohne jeden Zweifel und es
den Arm in China sehr viel dreckiger
geht als in jedem europäischen Land oder
weitgehend auch in den USA klar keine
Frage aber es gibt das Versprechen das
Versprechen das bei uns zunehmend
schlechter funktioniert das ist das was
dort nach wie vor funktioniert und du
siehst auch alles Handeln von Ching ping
und seinen Leuten ist im Grunde
ausgerichtet dass dieses
wohlstandsversprechen der Aufstieg dass
dieses Versprechen weiter funktioniert
und ich hatte nur ganz kleiner sousagen
Schritt zur Seite ich hab dieser Tage
gesehen wie viral ging die Klage einer
jungen Frau im Netz die sagt es kann
auch nicht sein ich muss zwischen 9 und
17 Uhr muss ich arbeiten und dann habe
ich nur 30 Tage Urlaub und ich verdien
kein Geld und so weiter und meine
Wohnung und wie soll ich das alles
bezahlen ich sehe meine Freunde nicht
mehr ich habe überhaupt keine Zeit mehr
für das Leben meine Work Life Balance
funktioniert nicht und dann fingen die
an zu weinen
und einige andere stimmten da auch mit
ein und du kannst dir vorstellen was
passiert ist die Häme war gigantisch ja
die über diese jungen Frauen da
hereingebrochen sind und ich habe mir
das da mal angesehen und dachte bin mir
nicht sicher ob wir da so hämisch sein
sollten das war wieder der vermeintliche
Beleg dafür ne die Generation Z und sind
alle faul und haben keinen Bock zu
arbeiten und so weiter und dann
willkommen in der Wirklichkeit und so
leben wir auch alle und ich dachte bin
mir nicht sicher ob diese These so
stimmt es gab nämlich zwei kleine
Details über die man stolpert wenn man
sich das mal anschaut das erste ist und
es hängt damit dem zweiten zusammen sie
sagt an einer Stelle ich brauche zwei
Stunden zur Arbeit zur Arbeitsstelle und
zwei Stunden wieder zurück das heißt
vier Stunden des Tages gehen nur dafür
drauf um zum Arbeitsplatz zu fahren und
der Hintergrund dafür ist und da kommt
jetzt Punkt 2 ins Spiel der Hintergrund
ist natürlich die kann sich die teure
Wohnung in der Innenstadt ich glaube es
war London nicht leisten das ist das
ganze Ding und das ist natürlich ein
frappierender Unterschied zu unserem
aufwachsen und Jung sein und anfangen
Erfolg zu haben ja wir konnten uns das
noch leisten da hat dieses Aufstieg
Versprechen an dem Punkt funktioniert
das war nicht großartig ich hab selber
als Praktikant und später volontaär und
so weiter irsinnig wenig Geld verdient
aber man konnte sich da irgendwie
durchmogeln und durchschlagen und das
funktioniert für diese junge Generation
nicht mehr und deswegen denke ich mal
Vorsicht an der warnsteinkante bevor wir
den dann wieder sagen du pass mal auf
was seid ihr alles für Weicheier das hat
mit weicheierigkeit wenig zu tun an dem
Punkt sondern die da da gibt es eine
berechtigte Klage über ein System dessen
ein zentrales versprechen nämlich das
aufstiegsversprechen nicht mehr
funktioniert ja als ich hab du das ist
ein ganz entscheidender Punkt den du da
and wenn wir die Frage beantworten
wollen wenn denn so viele Länder in den
90er Jahren liberale Demokratien
geworden sind so wie Fukuyama prophezeit
hat warum hat das nicht weiter Schule
gemacht und das liegt unter anderem
daran das ist eine Hypothese ja dass
viele dieser liberalen Demokratien
dieses dauerhafte wohlstandsversprechen
für die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung nicht
hat aufrecht erhalten können das heißt
also es ist nicht genau das eingetreten
was z.B in der Bundesrepublik
eingetreten ist in den 60er Jahren 50er
60er 70er 80er Jahren sondern viele
haben ganz andere Entwicklung genommen
obwohl sie liberale Demokratien sind das
heißt also der soziale Frieden ist da
nicht eingetreten der be uns in erster
Linie durch den Wohlstand eingetreten
ist und Länder die die wenn man sagt was
sind die friedlichsten Länder der Welt
ne ohne dass ich das jetzt gemessen habe
dann käme ich auf sowas wie Dänemark
Luxemburg Schweiz und so ja WCH sind sie
die gekennzeichnet fast keine Armut und
eine breite Mittelschicht ja genau und
überall wo das gegeben ist also wo wenig
Armut ist wo es breite Mittelschichten
gibt da gibt es meistens ein relativ
hohes Maß an politischer
Zufriedenheit aber es gibt eben liberale
Demokratien bei denen genau das nicht
funktioniert hat ne und diese berühmte
Sache mit der eine Millionen Mal
erzählten Schere zwischen Arm und Reich
und so weiter ist immer
potenzieller Konfliktstoff
unzufriedenheitsstoff Stoff der
Populisten Auftritt gibt und in solchen
schwierigen Gemengelagen werden Länder
dann wieder instabil und dann kann es
eben sein dass sie kippen ja dass sie
sich wieder entliberalisieren und
entdemokratisieren und das war was was
fukoyama damals also ich schätze den ja
ne ich hatte mit ihm eine sehr gute
fernsehesendung gemacht h den ja auch
mal kennengelernt und so weiter der
sieht das ja alles selber so der fragt
sich ja auch ja mittlerweile seit über
30 Jahren warum das nicht so gekommen
ist wie er sich das damals erhofft hat
und der analysiert das ja auch sehr
genau er hat ja ein Buch geschrieben
über Identitätspolitik indem er gesagt
hat wenn wenn die wenn die sozialen
Versprechen nicht aufgehen ja dann
ziehen die Leute sich nicht auf das
zurück was alle verbindet sondern sie
suchen ihre Identität in dem was sie von
den anderen unterscheidet und das
destabilisiert auf die Dauer die
Gesellschaft na er hat ja z.B der Linken
in den USA vorgeworfen dass sie sich
nicht mehr für die Arbeiterschaft
interessiert sondern dass sie Linken in
erster Linie an den Hochschulen zu
finden sind und sich eben für Gender
Fragen und wognness Fragen und so
interessieren und damit die
Arbeiterschaft nicht mehr vertreten ist
und dass die unzufriedene Arbeiterschaft
in erster Linie das Potenzial für Trump
wedder W dass die diese Arbeiterschaft
also die in Amerika ja nie besonders
links war ja dass die aber dann so
richtig rechts geworden ist zwei Sachen
dazu zwei Anmerkungen Francis wukuyama
hat das vor der eigenen Haustür ne der
lehrt in Stanford äh und da musst du nur
einmal weiter nach San Francisco Reisen
und dann siehst du eine eine gefallene
Stadt das ist ein Albtraum also und
nirgendwo ist ist der Unterschied
zwischen Arm und Reich so frappierend
wie in der Bay Area es sind ein paar
wenige super super super reiche und der
Rest kämpft haben wir schon paar mal
drüber gesprochen 130 000$
Jahreseinkommen und dann sagt die Stadt
ah der ist hart an der Armutsgrenze
müssen wir aufpassen die Gretchen Frage
wenn das so ist ja dass die der der
Hegemon die USA an Bedeutung verlieren
dass in allererst in Asien aber
zunehmend auch der globale Süden ein
politischer Player wird der nach ganz
anderen Spielregeln spielt und der der
andere Interessen hat der andere
Traditionen hat ja so einem erheblichen
Teil eben keine demokratischen
Traditionen sondern eben anokratische
oder autokratische und so weiter wenn
diese riesige Veränderung da ist und
wenn wir uns auch einig sind darin dass
sie sich nicht wirklich aufhalten
ist wie soll dann ein Land wie
Deutschland mit dieser Situation umgehen
ist die große Frage ne ich ähm hab
dieser Tage herfred Münkler gelesen der
sagt wir erleben tatsächlich eine
Wiederkehr quasi der Geschichte der sagt
wir wir wir Deutschen müssen da
aufpassen während andere Interessen
formulieren kommen wir immer mit mit
Moral und versuchen die anderen zu
erziehen das nervt die zunehmend
china ist schon als Stichwort gefallen
da muss man mal Egon Bar zitieren wenn
ein Politiker anfängt über Werte zu
schwadronieren statt seine Interessen zu
benennen dann wird es höchste Zeit den
Raum zu verlassen und das stellt dann
plötzlich weil du sagst Gretchen frrage
die Frage an uns okay wie gehen wir denn
jetzt damit um also halten wir unsere
Werte hoch versuchen wir dann auch
entsprechend aufzutreten die zu
formulieren wie es unsere
Außenministerin beispielsweise tut oder
gehen wir sozusagen mal eine Stufe
runter und sagen pass auf wir treten
jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen anders
auf um nicht zu sagen demütiger
versuchen niemanden zu belehren sondern
formulieren sehr klar unsere Interessen
und da gibt es zwei Lager in welchem
Lager stehst du da Richard ja also die
beiden Lager sind die einen sagen lass
mal den ganzen wertequatsch Weg ne es
ist ein bisschen sinngemäß das was
herfred Münkler sagt äh sondern Länder
haben Interessen und nichts als
Interessen und es geht darum eine
geschickte kluge diplomatische
Interessenspolitik zu machen ja das ist
auch ähnlich was Henry Kissinger in
letzten Jahren immer wieder und immer
wieder gesagt hat ja also weg mit den
Werten und so weiter sondern kluge
diplomatische Interessenspolitik das ist
die eine Fraktion die andere Fraktion
Werte geleitete Außenpolitik ja sehr
stark dadurch bestimmt ist dass wir eben
auch in anderen Ländern Auftreten und
den sagen was uns daran nicht gefällt
und immer von westlichen Werten sprechen
denken an Frauenrechte an Pressefreiheit
und vieles andere mehr wir wir teilen
die die Welt auf in Gut und Böse um es
mal ganz ganz flach zu SEAG ne genau
also wie jeder der moralisiert ja
unterscheidet er das was er achtet von
dem was er ächtet und unsere
Außenpolitik ist da jetzt nicht mehr so
diplomatisch sondern sagt das was sie
echtet spricht sie ganz klar aus ne und
sagt also es gibt sozusagen Gut und Böse
in der Welt und wir sind die guten so
das sind jetzt die beiden Pole und meine
persönlich habe schreib ja gerade ein
Buch D drüber meine persönliche Ansicht
ist das erste ist zu wenig also nur
Interessen geht glaube ich im 21
Jahrhundert nicht mehr ja dafür ist die
Welt digital virtuell und real viel zu
nah zusammengerückt und vor allen Ding
wir haben Interessen die ganz eng mit
Werten Zusammenhängen die wir mit allen
Menschen auf dieser Erde Teilen nämlich
das Überleben der Menschheit zu sichern
also der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel ja
gegen die die drohende Klimakatastrophe
gegen die ökologische Verseuchung der
der Länder und der Meere gegen die
Abholzung der Wälder und so weiter das
ist eine globale Herausforderung die a
den
überlebensinteressen der Menschen
entspricht und die B als
wichtigster globaler Wert verankert sein
müsste ja vor allem anderen wir müssen
also eigentlich eine Priorisierung
machen und da kam käme an allererster
Stelle käme eben das gemeinsam Interesse
und die gemeinsamen Werte der Ökologie
und der zweite wäre die frappierende
soziale Ungleichheit spricht den Hunger
in der Welt und alles was damit
zusammenhängt als zentralen Wert
anzuerkennen dagegen vorzugehen und
alles zu tun um das Schlimmste zu
verhindern und das gemeine ist ja auch
noch das erste und das zweite hängen
unmittelbar zusammen also die Art wie
wir wirtschaften und unsere ökologische
Bilanz und unser CO2 Ausstoß ist
maßgeblich mit für die versteöppung in
Afrika und die Ernteausfälle und und und
den klimatischen Auswirkungen ob es
Überschwemmung oder dürren sind
mitverantwortlich das als sozusagen
Zentrum als Kompass zu nehmen ja für
Werte die über allen anderen
Partikularinteressen stehen das z.B
finde ich unglaublich wichtig sich daran
zu orientieren das wäre für mich ja eine
Werte geleitete Außenpolitik die wir
dringend brauchen die anderen Sachen
sind auch wichtig ich will dir nicht von
von mal ebeno wegwischen ja aber das
sind sozusagen die prioritären
Herausforderung und der letzte Satz das
lenkt den Blick auf das was wir Menschen
alle miteinander teilen und keine Werte
geleitete Politik die den Blick immer
auf das lenkt was wir nicht teilen mhm
was interessant ist ist man könnte mal
einen anderen Begriff
in die in die Debatte werfen oder
sousagen an an an andere Art zu denken
das verstehst du wenn du in dem Buch von
Florence gaub sprichst aus dem ich
vorhin zitiert habe ja ft denk mal über
Zukunft nach die Wahlplakate in Bayern
und in Hessen haben etwas sehr
Interessantes gezeigt jetzt in den
letzten Landtagswahlen die allermeisten
Parteien Fischen sozusagen in der
Gegenwart die Versprechen dass alles so
bleibt wie es ist und die AFD verspricht
die Vergangenheit ja aber die Zukunft
wird im Grunde nicht beackert und
Florence gaup weiß in in dem Buch nach
dass ist wirklich spannend in den
letzten 20 Jahren und das das das zeigen
Studien auch das kann man belegen hat
sich Politik immer weniger mit
Zukunftsszenarien beschäftigt wir haben
es uns quasi in der Gegenwart gemütlich
gemacht so sagt sie das und angenommen
es geht einfach immer so weiter und dass
wir dann unser Modell der Demokratie so
wie wir sie kennen exportieren und so
weiter haben dabei völlig übersehen dass
riesiger Wohlstand auch in ganz anderen
Systemen geht Stichwort China du kannst
eine Autokratie sein und trotzdem
funktioniert die nach den Regeln
arabischen Staaten lange vor China war
das so die Golfstaaten ja lupenreine
Autokratien ja waren schon enorm
kapitalistisch erfolgreich
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich ohne
ansatzweise irgendetwas liberales oder
demokratisches erkennen zu lassen schon
damals hätte man merken müssen jetzt
reden wir ja schon vor Jahrzehnten war
das ja schon so ja dass dieser Link den
wir machen zwischen liberalen
Demokratien entspricht wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich der ist nicht falsch aber
der ist an viele viele Voraussetzungen
gebunden und es gibt wichtige Ausnahmen
von dieser Regel und die können auch
dazu führen dass unter anderem eben
autokratische Regime wirtschaftlich sehr
erfolgreich sind nicht gerade der
staatskommunismus der war nirgendwo
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich aber andere
Systeme können das schon genau und Gau
sagt eben das hat was damit zu tun dass
sie in längeren Zeithorizonten denken
also in Kulturen wie südkorea Japan und
so weiter das das zeigen Studien da wird
in längeren Zeithorizonten gedacht die
USA z.B war das erste Land der Welt in
dem das Streben nach Glück Teil der
Verfassung geworden ist sehr interessant
Rat Mal in Europa wer ist der Zukunft
Spitzenreiter welches Land macht sich am
meisten Gedanken um die Zukunft
wahrscheinlich irgendein nordisches Land
richtig Finnland und die die These ist
das hat damit zu tun die haben die haben
diesen bedrohlichen Nachbarn ja diese
Nähe zu Russland und das hat die
sozusagen gezwungen sich schon sehr früh
mit ihrer Zukunft möglicherweise auch
bösen Zukunft auseinanderzusetzen aber
das ist interessant da gibt es auf allen
politischen Ebenen ja so vom Stadtrat
bis zum Parlament gibt es sogenannte
zukunftsausschüsse total spannend setzen
sich einmal im Jahr zusammen um
gemeinsam darüber
nachzudenken wie die Zukunft aussehen
könnte und bei uns merkst Du ganz häufig
und deswegen glaube ich kommt auch so
dieses Gefühl wir wir wir sind so
hilflos und wir reagieren immer nur noch
das kommt aus dieser Kurzatmigkeit und
ich glaube dass der zweite Punkt der
dabei eine Rolle spielt ist sicherlich
unsere mediale Welt ich meine unsere
Eltern haben früher einmal am Abend um
20 Uhr die Tagesschau eingeschaltet wir
stecken heute alle ich sag mal mental
den ganzen Tag mit dem Kopf im Sand von
Gaza den ganzen Tag ne die ganze Zeit
und diese das lässt uns keinen Raum mehr
um einmal wirklich durchzuatmen ich
glaube an diesen an diesen beiden
Schrauben darüber werden wir Irmer
nachdenken müssen ja es ist schon eine
lange bekannte Diagnose dass sie halt
eine Diktatur der Gegenwart über die
anderen Zeiten haben also wir sind immer
geschichtsvergessener und wir denken
immer weniger an die Zukunft sondern wir
haben so eine Diktatur des jetzt die die
nimmt uns komplett gefangen und in einer
medienaufregungsdemokratie die wir hier
sind führt das natürlich auch dazu dass
die Politik unausgesetzt im jetzt zum
jetzt Stellung nehmen muss ich habe das
glaube ich in ein früheren Podcast mal
gesagt ich wünschte mal jemand würde
erforschen wie oft Adenauer eigentlich
Pressekonferenzen gegeben hat oder mit
Journalisten gesproch
ich glaub das ist nicht besonders häufig
vorgekommen ja da war dann am Anfang mal
da hatten die meisten Leute kein
Fernsehen in der Wochenschau irgendwie
zu sehen also der hat wahrscheinlich
deutlich längere Tage damit verbracht
sich nicht mit Journalisten zu
unterhalten man stelle sich das gleiche
meine heutigen Form vor undi mal Olaf
Scholz ist da nicht so weit weg also der
der kommuniziert auch eher ü oder über
Regierungssprecher oder was weiß ich was
oder so aber du musst eigentlich heute
ein unausgesetzter Kommunikator sein
wenn du in der Politik bist undau
unausgesetzter Kommentator von möglichst
allem und allem was gerade
ansteht und wie sollst du dann wenn du
in dieser Rolle bist noch wirklich
langfristig Politik machen das hat wir
haben überall taktikfüchse in der
Politik die überlegen was gerade
situativ besonders gut ist aber wir
haben systembedingt kann man sagen
Mediendemokratie keine Strategen mehr
mhm letzter Punkt Richard äh um um nicht
so so düster da rauszugehen
Zukunftsvision wo ist die Welt in 50
Jahren Florence gaub sagt die Vision vom
friedlichen Nahen Osten ist möglich so
schrecklich diese Angriffe der Hamas
waren so schrecklich das ist was gerade
in Gaza passiert die könnten eine
Kettenreaktion auslösen halt dich für
denkbar in 50 Jahren könnte die Ukraine
Mitglied der NATO und auch der EU sein
ich weiß gar nicht ob es in 50er Jahren
noch eine NATO oder eine EU gibt ich
finde ich finde in 50 Jahren viel viel
viel zu lange in 50 jahreen leben wir
beide nicht mehr ja gut das ist 50
Jahren kann die Menschheit aus
ausgelöscht sein in 50er Jahren 50
Jahren kann alles wieder schön sein der
Zeitraum ist doch viel zu lang um
irgendeine seriöse Prognose zu machen
also ich finde schon die Frage zu
stellen was in den nächsten 5 bis 10
Jahren passiert schon dafür haben wir
doch für all die großen Fragen überhaupt
keine Lösung also weder was die Ukraine
anbelangt noch was nach Ost anbelangt
oder so also ein Stratege überlegt nicht
wie die Welt in 50 Jahren ist sondern
der überlegt sich ein Ziel was innerhalb
der nächsten 10 Jahre erreichbar ist ja
vielleicht auch das ich glaube trotzdem
dass z.B Russland git Leute die sagen
die werden jetzt auch noch eingreifen
und dann dann werden die werden die ein
Flächenbrand entfachen ich sehe das and
ich GLB die sind viel zu erschöpft auch
gerade militärisch äh das an der Stelle
wird da nichts passieren Iran ja das ist
die große Frage das ist die große Frage
ist das spannungsverälnis zwischen den
USA und dem Iran und da gibt es
ernstzunehmende Leute die sagen Iran die
brechen nicht den großen Krieg vom Zaun
weil gutes Argument finde ich können die
sich innenpolitisch gerade gar nicht
leisten die stehen bei ihrer eigenen
Bevölkerung mit dem Rücken zur Wand die
die die sind durch bei den Leuten das
ist gegen diese Bevölkerung nicht zu
machen ist ein guter Punkt und wäre auch
ein Stück Hoffnung ja der Punkt ist auch
nicht dass ich glaube dass dass der Iran
jetzt eine Großoffensive startet gegen
Israel sondern die große Gefahr besteht
ähnlich da wie an deinem petrof Beispiel
ja dass also kleine scherützel Vorfälle
hier da da gibt's plötzlich ein
Giftgasangriff da das da wird der
dahinter vermutet und so weiter und dass
dann eine Verkettung der verschiedenen
Ursachen zu einem Krieg führt wie beim
Ersten Weltkrieg den in dieser Form
keiner will das ist eigentlich aus
meiner Sicht die größte Gefahr und nicht
die größte Gefahr dass es jetzt einen
massiven Angriffskrieg von der einen
oder anderen Seite aufeinander gibt mhm
sieh und da hoffen wir es einfach zum
Schluss dass an dem Tag an der Stelle
wieder ein Stanislav Petrov sitzt und
das verhindern wird Richard ich danke
Dir sehr ja ich danke dir auch bis
nächste Woche alles Gute dir bis nächste
Woche ja Tschüss Markus
Ciao eine Produktion von mh2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF